there's so much going on with comedy
right now you you were performing a
comedy unleashed by the time this video
goes out it will already have happened
yes it's a show that we've talked about
we've both performed there there's been
an article recently they came out about
that there's lots of discussion about
free speech one of the biggest stories I
think that's happened recently has been
the Joe brand case and for anyone who
doesn't know Joe brand made the joke
about how instead of milk shaking I
don't know she said far-right
politicians that she didn't agree with
yeah
what we should do instead is for a
battery acid yes and then she was saying
this as part of a comedy performance on
a comedy program yes but I think a lot
of the stuff that came out of that and I
talked about it was the double standards
of left versus right freedom of speech
for comedians freedom of speech in
general the ability to make jokes what
was your take on that situation well
there are a number of salient factors I
think the most obvious one to say is
that yes of course it was a joke but I
think it was a joke which on a moment's
reflection you would see was probably
not an appropriate thing to broadcast on
radio for at a point where tensions were
very high and I think the people half
the reason that milk shaking is such a
an effective tool is because it arouses
a brief moment of panic in the victim
when they don't know what's been thrown
at them you know and I think people live
in in genuine fear of being attacked by
something more serious
so I think a moment's reflection would
have made anyone realize that it wasn't
an appropriate thing to broadcast and
that moment should have then been
grasped by the various you know rafts of
authority and editing processes and the
producers and so on who would have
mediated between Joe saying it and the
audience laughing but a little nervously
I think and a sort of 24 hour gap at
least before it's broadcast so I
certainly don't blame Joe Brand at all
for a misjudgment or an error of taste
or whatever because as I think we've all
discussed before now if you ought to be
able to function as a comedian you'll
have to be able to cross the line
realize you've crossed it and retreat
without having your career in tatters
you know without having a police
investigation people refer to edgy
comedians perhaps without really
considering what the word means well for
me it means the edge of what is
acceptable and you transgress it
occasionally and you play with it even
if you just do a live gig in front of a
comedy club audience every comedian is
always pushing up see where there
their collective ages and one or two
people will feel you've crossed it at
any given point and then you come back
and for some people you know making a
joke at the expense of let's say down
syndrome will be something that's beyond
the pale and they just won't accept it
and Frankie Boyle got into travel with
with a joke like that a few years ago
having done other material in which he
quite literally you know decapitates
politicians and vomits into their riding
trunks you know so it's not necessarily
I don't think it should be imposed on
Joe brand but having said all that it
was a tiny bit of schadenfreude that I
enjoyed bit in seeing her held up to
account because she herself has called
other people on that kind of stuff you
know she she famously had Carol fatter
essentially you know blackballed from
any further employment prospects at the
BBC after an off-the-cuff remark she
made you know in the green room I think
a slightly old-fashioned a misjudged
joke that she made but it wasn't I don't
think it was fueled by hate or any sort
of vicious racism or anything will Joe
brand reported that Carol Thatcher never
worked again whether whether that was
not intended as revenge for Joe brands
quite open loathing for her mother for
Margaret Thatcher I don't know but it
seemed to be an extraordinary
coincidence if it wasn't and and then
she quite recently scolded Ian Hislop of
course live on on have I got news for
you when his slop was essentially
chortling at the notion that a bit of a
sort of clumsy Negro pin the Commons
canteen was on the same level of me to
horror story you know there's as the
weinstein revelations and so on it was
all being collected in under the hashtag
me too i think a journalist i come over
as a journalist you know attempted to
grope an MP or vice versa okay yeah so
and it wasn't you know it was it wasn't
like he wasn't saying it doesn't matter
but he was kind of joking that it's not
really quite on the same level as these
hollywood revelations and joe deliver
this kind of minute long monologue
telling him that this kind of thing just
wears you down and got a round of
applause but essentially she was
policing his sense of humor and his
sense of proportion and telling him no
this matters
that's all that everyone else has done a
lot of other people have them police
don't know sorry but when you are a
public figure you do live in fear now of
a serious assault on the street and this
kind of thing doesn't help and if it had
been the left who had been given an
opportunity to castigate a right-wing
comedian for joking about something they
would immediately have you know brought
up the Joe Cox murder and so on as
indications will be exactly why these
kind of things are not to be joked about
so I think there has been a huge amount
of hypocrisy but none of it I would say
in all seriousness should hinder any
comedian from cracking any joke they
want to make you know it's certainly in
like a non live scenario because it was
then expected that the producers will
clean that up and go actually that on
reflection doesn't really work for us
and so we're just gonna slip it out
which of course they did in the later
editions
[Music]